الاسماك المملحه او الفسيخ اكله يحبها
المصريون في عيد شم النسيم الذي يحل يوم
الاثنين القادم وكنا نظن ان قدوم هذا
اليوم في رمضان سيقلل من الاقبال على شراء
الفسيخ ولكن تبين غير ذلك كما يحكي لنا
شريف اليماني من مدينه نبروه في محافظه
الدقهليه وهي من معاقل صناعه الفسيخ في
مصر رغم الغله لكن ما حدش بيقدر يستغنى عن
الاكله دي بالذات سواء في شم النسيم او في
او في العيد هم الاتنين برضو جايين ورا
بعض يعني خلاص شم النسيم السنه دي الاخوه
والاخبار المسيحيين من اول اسبوع في رمضان
وهم شغالين على السيخ لحد النهارده وبكره
لانه منهم اللي بياخذ بدري ومنهم اللي
معتاد بياخد قبل شم النسيم بيومين وبالفعل
وجدنا زبائن مسلمين ومسيحيين جاؤوا للشراء
وبينهم عاملان مشتركان الاول عشق الفسيخ
والثاني
لا عموما اللي شم النسيم وكما حدث لجميع
السلع فقد ضرب الغلاء الاسماك واثر هذا
بالتالي على اسعار الفسيخ بلد فيها ثروه
سمكيه زي دي النهارده يبقى فيها كيلو فسيخ
عندي انا على الاقل ما ليش
ب 230 جنيه
كتير جدا مش منطقي من الواضح ان صوم رمضان
لم يثني المصريين عن تناول الاسماك
المملحه خلال الشهر الفضيل او حتى في
الاحتفالات بالاعياد تامر نصرت العربيه
مدينه نبروه محافظه الدقهليه